يتمدد دور الذكاء الاصطناعي ليصل الى
مهنتنا نحن الاعلاميون اذ اصبح هذا الذكاء
قادرا على انتاج الفيديو وكتابه المقالات
وحتى قراءه نشره الاخبار
وبحسب المدير التنفيذي لمجموعه الاعلام
الالمانيه فان الصحفيين معرضون لخطر
استبدالهم بانظمه ذكاء اصطناعي مثل تشاد
وسيكون البرنامج افضل في تجميع المعلومات
من الصحفيين البشر الشركه المطوره لتشات
جي بي تي كشفت ان التحديث الرابع للروبوت
يمكنه من انشاء وتحرير النصوص ككتابه
سيناريوهات او تعلم اسلوب كتابه المستخدم
كما انه متعدد الوسائط فيمكنه اخراج النص
بناء على الصور
يمكنه ايضا اختصار الوقت في عمليه البحث
والوصول الى المعلومه بشكل اسرع كما ان
الروبوت يبسط القضايا المعقده للجمهور مع
سماحه بادخال ملخص او جزء من مقال اكاديمي
لغرض تسهيل وصول المعلومه واخيرا يساعد
الروبوت الذكي في وضع اسئله المقابلات
ونسخ مقابلات سابقه او حتى مقاله كتبها
الشخص الذي تمت مقابلته وتطوير اسئله حول
هذا الموضوع
اول مذيعه في الكويت تعمل بذكاء الاصطناعي
في مؤسسه كويت نيوز الاعلاميه ما هي نوعيه
الاخبار التي تفضلونها لنسمع ارائكم
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات